looks like a lot it's a lot of beans
[Music]
hello I'm Chloe
I represent Britain hi my name is Shawn
I'm representing Team Korea hey well hi
I'm Tom I'm from England
I'm hazel I'm from South Korea and today
we are trying each of the snacks I don't
know a lot about Korean snacks I just
realized this I don't know any British
snacks my favourite food is actually
like no joke fish and chips so that's
the only thing I know about British food
I don't know much about Korean snacks
I'm a fitness trainer so I don't really
have any sort of sweet food ever so this
will be exciting I don't think I've had
any British food ever I don't think our
British restaurants here oh these are
Maltesers bear molt flavoured whisky
stuff on the inside I'm gonna say
biscuit I mean American biscuit I mean
like cookie and these are extremely
light well I mean they're probably quite
heavy in terms of calories so these are
called homerun balls they're just little
balls and they were just filled with
chocolate so pretty straightforward I
don't think you're gonna have any issues
with them have you had a cream puff yeah
that's so like the texture is like a
cream puff but then inside its chocolate
thank you okay
do you know what's on the outside I
don't know it's kind of like a pastry
like oh really really light it's just
kind of crunchy yeah don't you think
girls come you can do it I will say
presentation-wise I think we won this I
think I mean it's you know it's a little
lazy children lazy Sharan children let's
see it listen I want and you tell me
that's actually not bad yeah I told you
nothing to worry about these are good
but they're like no but they they just
draw on the outside that's all but
that's like a cream coat isn't a cream
puffs right I mean when he gets the
center it's fine who's this chocolate in
the middle it's very light it's actually
lighter than the Maltesers yeah these
are really heavy these are kind of like
the opposite I don't know how to
describe it but it's like what like it's
not dry but it's not a good sensation
that I'm getting away I don't know well
screw you I probably wouldn't buy okay
they just like their textures is not my
thing they were just they're crunchy I
don't really like crunchy I would
actually probably go with the homerun
balls as well yeah on three one two
three Jesus oh no no no I really do like
these for these oh I like this game over
this game over okay this is SEC SEC do
you like grape flavored things I do I
like grape flavored things I like grapes
that's about it I don't even drink wine
but these are like iconic Korean drinks
yeah probably taste closer to real grape
then okay other things when there's a
chance I won't hate that which is nice I
loved it when I was a kid so I'm gonna
be offended if you don't like it those
are the interesting thing about this one
is that there's like actual grapes at
the bottom so it's like always this game
where you finish the juice and they try
to like suck out the grapes from the can
so this is what a lot of kids do
drinking at the UK it is full of
essentially blackberries and sugar well
I feel like you're gonna win
because this is just kind of I mean I
love this but it's like syrupy and you
like just add water to it so you dilute
it so this is like concentrate do not do
this because if we drink it straight
some people do but if you drink it
straight it's it's way too strong and if
you are sick as a child a nice little
sort of cure-all or whatever is just to
have this heated heart this is like
cough syrup except it has no effect on
health other than to sugar sugar all
right good luck have fun
it smells like black or is it black
curanto planet current current okay okay
well that's not how you spell card but I
know you guys got your own spelling over
there but just water like okay you need
more yeah I will say I will say I
personally don't drink juice I think if
you like juice you would really like
this okay
this so this is good it's good I want to
drink this personally but I think anyone
who loves juice would like this do you
see you do you have to drink it with
water people just drink it straight some
people do is I'm kind of tempted to yeah
people on the margins of British society
drink it straight it's the sort of as a
hippie thing yeah I have like a sip it's
like kool-aid yeah yeah go ahead I'm
feeling adventurous today that's okay
this is really good this is really
actually quite similar to that in that
it's not fizzy isn't like fruit juice
right this isn't like 100% grape juice
you know that's actually really nice I'm
very surprised and it actually looks
okay now there's a lot of added sugar
Cup some say it looks healthy it's not
no it's not but it tastes nice how much
did you drink because I feel you gotta
get the great party
let's drink the whole thing yes chug it
[Music]
oh yeah there's like whole great right
yeah I would vote for this one over that
one and II agree
of course pace wise I'll go with this
one experience wise I'll stick with this
I actually like that a lot
I think I've actually choose that
because it's different and unique and I
haven't really had anything like that
what'd you think of it what is that
it's tasting butter oh that's butter
well I mean that's a lot yeah that's a
lot of butter
[Music]
hush hush
[Applause]
it's this old concentrations these are
baked beans but they're not American
baked beans in that they are not
barbecue flavor bitter flavor Oh looks
like a lot it's a lot of beans it's a
lot of beans it has to pile up otherwise
it's not fun so this is hot soup and
it's basically red bean porridge and
even though it's sweet it's not always a
dessert like people eat it during meals
I would say usually the older generation
like this more I'm starting to get there
I think so yeah I'm pretty old so enjoy
this is that too much or too little
[Music]
Yass good this is good enough that's
great yeah take some things off a bit
much
those are the best bits otherwise you
can eat them after me good
that's nice actually I do I've had baked
beans before in America and I do like
regular baked beans and I do like that
it's not as like super sweet as regular
barbecue beans it tastes exactly what it
looks like you know like kind of you get
what you see I'm not like a huge fan of
beans so again I probably wouldn't eat
it
this is insanely sweet but it's good no
I like it though it's definitely more I
would eat it as a dessert way it's sort
of like a kidney bean soup as a health
freak I probably avoid it just with all
the sugar but I actually quite like the
I have to say I like this pace Wow yeah
thank you
yeah I think only because I grew up with
might be insane miss them so much being
here I'm actually gonna go with this as
well like I said I don't like super
sweet things so red bean is usually a
bit too sweet and really knowing what
those taste like I would definitely
choose these me too I was pretty
impressed with your snacks I really
liked it was yeah I didn't hate any of
them I liked most of them I just think
our snacks
I had a slight more preference towards
yeah but I did like all the snacks here
so I was actually very pleasantly
surprised by all of this I didn't know
what to expect with Korean cuisine I've
never really had it before it makes me
actually went to visit Korea sometime
yeah you should we'd love to have you I
learned that there's no British
restaurants for beef
I'm sorry I think it's fair yes we have
good restaurants in Britain but none are
actually specifically British
restaurants how's it work like I'm just
gonna get toastin being spy yeah we
could just make that at home right uh
yes although I think you've just come up
with a really great business idea I
think you should go into business
together it beans on toast around the
clock in LA we could make a fortune wait
okay you let me know how that goes
[Music]
[Music]